what's exciting that the GigaPan is that
it's a
device that combines a non technol
with a
a robot that allows you to take pictures
that have more resolution and more
panoramic capabilities than anything
that exists in the world today ordinary
photography is a really powerful medium
for communicating ideas and
communicating across culture but the
gigapan is really a storytelling device
it's something that allows one party to
make a picture in a scene like a dining
table or a spice market in Tanzania and
through that picture annotated with
stories and information and videos and
sounds and so it really is almost like
you're making a movie that's specially
custom designed so that anybody around
the world can explore this world in a
whole new way gigapan and all of the
Global Connections project is
fundamentally about connecting people to
each other and to the environment in
other words to our world and we measure
success by seeing the degree to which
we're really causing meaningful
interactions and conversations that
hopefully improve the world over time so
if people are humanizing each other if
there's conversations happening between
people who would never talk to each
other and if people's value systems are
changing a little bit so that socially
they are more at one with each other
than we're succeeding
you